welcome everybody
i am materos alvareza i work at warfare
research
in the machine learning team um
and today i will present a
system to implement
to add basically generic
custom layers to the neural network
framework
so um
[Music]
there will be a new um net layer in
terms of called combined layer
which leverages the warfarm compiler to
basically enable
uh general purpose uh computation inside
the the framework so the framework has
layers building blocks and it's already
quite flexible you can already quite do
quite a lot of things by combining them
but this
should basically unlock whatever uh
the new compiler can do so function
compile
okay i'll make a brief introduction
about the new compiler
uh very quick so we have two compilers
in the system the old one
using the function called compile and
the new one from
12 version 12 which is function compile
so and this is what we're going to focus
on so function compile
takes function objects and compiles them
to level code producing
compile code function objects
as with every compiler you argument
should be tight
there is some type system
into play so i cannot just feed
any function to function compile with a
generic argument because
it will complain saying that this is not
typed
the way function compile works is you
have to specify the types for the
arguments so for example here i'm
creating two functions
one taking a real number and this one
taking an integer
both computing just adding one to the
input and you see here that
the compiled code function gives you the
signature input and output types
so i obviously have to fit the right
input to
both functions so i have to feed the
floating point number to a frill and an
integer number to have
int if i try to do the opposite the
function will complain
fixed sorry arrays can also be
[Music]
specified they actually have fixed depth
both factories and numeric arrays are
possible so for example this
is a compiled function taking two
arguments
one is attacked array of real numbers
with that two and one is a fact array of
real numbers with that one
and this is the computation it's going
to care to
do
we can create inputs on the correct size
of the word depth
random through the function
we can also do the same for numeric
arrays
uh so basically packed arrays are
basically nested lists
where numerically are actual numeric
arrays which is the
[Music]
object in the language
and so you you you can also create you
see the scene user says numeric array
here
and this thing has to take numerical as
input and produce
mercury outputs
so this is what will this is what
compiled layer we will be using
more information about the compiler you
can check the compiler talk from
yesterday
and also the system augmentation for
these functions here
so let's go to compile layer
okay so basically compiling layer allows
a function
suitable for compilation for function
compile to be used in the neural network
framework
since in neural networks we deal with
arrays only array arguments are allowed
so either numeric or packed arrays not
scalars basically
okay so here i have defined the function
which is suitable for compilation
i did not compile this function so this
is
an ordinary function object still
this is what i'm going to pass to
compile layer to create a layer out of
this function
so what happens under the hood is that
compiled layer will compile this
function
using function compile with some
internal settings
suitable for using the framework so
this triggers compilation and then we
build the layer and give us the
compiled layer
compilation is still quite slow but it
can improve in future
and this is probably now
not sure what it's taking it's okay so
that's it
so one important comment to make one
important limitation of compiled layer
is that
in 12 2 only function taking a single
input will be allowed
for multiple input and output layer
parts
they will be added in future versions
okay so
let's let's start playing with compiled
layer
so one um one interesting
uh aspect is the shape inference
so basically um
depending on the function input depth
which is in the signature and the layer
input depth which is specified layer
construction time
compiled layer can interpret the
the function as either taking a single
example as input or a batch
for example as an input so for example
if i define adapt3 function
there's a three here and a three layer
because i specify
an input of that three then the function
is said we can call it unbatched which
means
compiled layer interprets this function
as acting on single examples
[Music]
so this is what you would normally
expect
basically um once the air is created you
will see that
yeah its input shape would be two three
four
and the output shape is two four so this
this shape here was filled by just
running this function under the hood and
see what the shape of the output is
okay so basically in this case it means
that
when given a single example of shape 2v4
this function is just run on the example
but when the layer is given a batch of
examples
the function is mapped over the batch so
here i'm defining
a single example of shape 234 and then a
batch of five examples
and this is a generic feature of the
neural network framework
layer can work on objects of both like
both of the you can give
both this and this thing as inputs the
layer and you see that the dimensions
in this case up to four which is what
the layer is telling you
and in the batch case is a batch of five
outputs with link to four
because we have we have put five
examples in inputs
okay so this is what you would normally
expect
the extra thing is that if the depth of
the function
is one more than the depth of the layer
then
the function is said to be batched which
means the layer interprets it as running
on batches of examples
so in this case function that is three
layer rank is two
this will now produce an array of length
four
and the input will be rank two what this
means is that
when given a bet when this layer is
given a bunch of examples
this function is evaluated once
on the full batch it's not mapped over
the batch
when when you give a single example to
the layer on the other hand the function
is evaluated over
basically a batch with batch size one
and everything works again as expected
it's basically
everything is
depth from one minus one with respect to
this case
okay so um
why why why does this exist this exists
because
batch mode can be useful for faster
processing
sometimes you you prefer to have
this function having the full batch
under control or
basically um easy
design speed is useful for batch
processing so sometimes
you do want basically different elements
of the batch to interact with each other
in your networks for example if you want
to do a variation of maturization layer
this is a layer that normalizes its
examples
over the batch so it needs to have
access to the entire batch you cannot
map it
over something okay
okay so a few words about numeric types
so
the compiler type system has several
real and integer types most of them are
from numeric array
you have 32 bits real and
64 bits real and then you get many
integer types both simon and sine with
various
bits that's plus
machine intelligent machinery for packed
array
so yeah basically you can
you can play around with this type
system you can you can create functions
which you know take
a numeric array of of some type and
produce numeric array of other types
um and and you have to respect those
string specifications
when running the compile function on the
other hand
uh the rule network framework does not
have all these granularity of types
we don't distinguish between bits for
example but we do
distinguish between real integers and so
basically what happens is that type
information is transferred from the
function signature to the layer port
types
so here for example i'm taking a
function which takes a real
and then takes the floor of it so the
compiler
recognizes this and so decides that
the output type must be an integer type
because i'm rounding it
and if we feed this function to the
compiled layer then
this will also be reflected on in the
integers being here so
vector size five in the framework means
that
uh it's reals if you don't see anything
it's reals if you see integers then it's
integer
and and so yeah this
information is transferred in over the
framework
okay um
this is the last and most complicated
part
training
so currently in order to be used in a
train
compile layer needs an additional
function to be defined
which is function defining its backward
password gradient propagation
so let's take a random function here
doing some random complicated
computation
and create a net using a compiled layer
created from this function and a
learnable layer which is an array inside
it so this netchain
if you try to train this network
training fails
because the framework tells us that the
net contains one or more compiled layer
with no gradient propagating function
for the same reasons gradients also
cannot be computed so
in the framework you can add this
property specification
to compute gradients but this doesn't
work if you
if you if you don't have a backward
propagating function
so what is this backward propagating
function um
for those not familiar with neural
networks basically
neural networks operators neural network
layers do
two type do two separate computations
basically
we have a four word propagation which
just computes takes an input and applies
a function computing the output which is
everything we've discussed so far and
then we have a backward propagation
which is used to compute gradients
across the network which is what need
what's needed for
optimization for training of course so
in backward propagation
you start from the input you
re you reuse the inputs and you also
start from a gradient coming from
outside so this is
you can see you can think of these as
relative to a single layer to a single
building block
in the in the network every layer
receives an output gradient from the
layer which comes
after it that's why it's called backward
and okay so these are this is the input
of the backward propagation
and what the backup regression computes
is basically the dot product between
this output gradient coming from the
outside and
the jacobian of the forward function
with respect to its input okay so this
is what
the backward function has to compute
uh now um so let's let's
let's add this function let's implement
this so
the turns out that for
the the language symbolic
differentiation capabilities are quite
useful to
implement these functions
so let's try basically to compute these
things symbolically
you know the alternative is working it
out on a paper basically or in your head
okay so we create a symbolic input for
example vector block five
and we run f which is our
forward function so this function
we run f on this input and get this
output which is a vector of size of size
four
the jacobian is just the symbolic
derivative of the output respect to the
input so we can use the
d function which is the symbolic
differentiation and we will have our
nice jacobian matrix
of dimensions eight comma five so output
size comma input size
okay so last step is to take the dot
product of this matrix
with an output gradient which i'll
define here
and this is the result so basically now
what we want is we want
we want to create a function which
computes this thing
and this is it this is a slightly
optimized implementation of this
so we get our green function okay
so notice that
um as i said the backward pass needs
two inputs
the the actual input from the forward
and the output gradients
but the function has just defined
takes three inputs it takes the input
takes the output gradient
and also takes the output so what is
this thing this
is basically
this quantity which was pre-computed
from
the previous forward pass and the reason
why this is made accessible to this
function
is that in general sometimes
the greater
the output so you can think as for
example the exponential function
so the the derivative of the exponential
function is the exponential itself
so if you were to you know implement a
gradient probability function for the
exponential
which you don't need to do because the
framework can do
the exponential exponentiation natively
but this is just for the sake of
argument
you just reuse this output but in
general it's something that
you know it can be it can it can be
useful to have
so this picture kind of
summarizes everything so
everything happened you know every time
you want to sometimes you just want to
repeat the forward pass so you you take
the input
you you give it to the forward function
you have the output and you're done
but if you'll do training or if you're
propagating gradient after you've done
this step you have to do this step
so in the backward pass you see this
backward function
blob has three inputs it uses the actual
input from the forward
it uses the output precomputed by the
forward which can optionally
be used to save time and it uses the
output gradient which comes from
the output so this is our o i vector
and this produces the input gradient
i got two questions
yeah so automatic differentiation i will
i will
come to that later how does compare
relate to function layer
good question so function layer
basically um
uh how much slower is function layer
well it depends
i actually well you actually expect
function layer to be
faster usually and the reason is that
function layer
compiles directly to um
basically function layer takes top level
workflow language code
and translates it to
net graphs that's what it does that
graphs
means that
you know in our framework and that graph
translates to an mx net graph
so it will natively use mxnet primitives
which
you expect and they generally are
to be very very optimized while with
function layer
you have potentially way more
flexibility because
you have um you you you can
and you can do everything the compiler
can do which in the long run
means you can everything the language
will be able to do but
you will not have a super optimized
implementation
you know created by a human in native c
plus plus code
so uh this is the difference function
layer
actually still translates to every layer
that
we are currently using in the framework
already so
as of now it's just a convenience
basically to to write net graph more
easily
function compiled layer is actually more
flexible and can do more things
yeah in the future they will probably
merge
which means that function function layer
which could become net function
will be able to
translate top level of language code
either in
that graphs but it can also compile some
intermediate pieces
into compiled layers so they will merge
at some point
okay
[Music]
okay so now that we have our gradient
function
we can just add it to the layer so it's
just the second argument here
and with this we are now equipped to do
training
and to do gradient computation
creation takes a little bit more because
it has to compile two functions now
i can create this network and now
grading computation works and training
also can start
okay so
that's it this is everything i
wanted to show so for future development
so this is compiling layer is is
promising
but it's quite limited what has to
happen is
multiple input output ports so create a
compiled layer
with two input ports from a function
with two arguments so right now
if i try to do it layer function must
take one type array as input
this is very important to have generic
computation of course
learnable arrays so it will be possible
to
create a compiled layer containing
learners inside it just like convolution
or linear layers or
i was still not sure how this is going
to happen
alternative option will be that through
this multi-input mechanism
you will basically be able to to make a
learnable compiled layer
by using a combination of multiple
inputs and that array layer
which is what prospero is called
concentrate layer
acting as holding the learnable arrays
from the layer
and this is one of the question
automatic differentiation so
um basically
um what we are able to do
in the near future would be to
uh automatically generate the gradient
propagating function
from before the the forward function
without asking the user to implement it
and this
will use the um the functionality
which has been mentioned in the question
which is compiled to the derivative code
function
um it's actually compiled to
a joint code function
but yes so
[Music]
well for 12 2 you might be
able to create
a you know you might be able to create
the
the backward propagating function
yourself using automatic differentiation
but in uh it will not be automatic so
you will still
have to plug manually the function in
into the layer uh but in the future
everything will be you know we will try
to do it automatically
so it will be much nicer
okay so this is yeah
that's the end of the presentation
um if anybody has questions please take
five minutes
is loop and if supported yes
as as far as it's supported in function
compile
it is the the only limitation is that
you you cannot produce uh for example in
a nif
with generic uh general purpose code you
can produce
very very different results in the two
branches of leave
while in neural networks you have you
still have
you have to prove you have to produce
arrays of course and you have to produce
arrays of the same shape
so because you cannot have you know
a layer like combined layer or anything
having an undefined output size here
which can be
two three three sometimes but some other
times it can be a
list of like that of length ten you
cannot have that so
uh output shape and also a
number of outputs must be the same but
then you can have inside yes
will this allow user-defined net
encoders decoders well
it doesn't need to because you can
already do it you can there is
the net encoder
function and you can you can have a
function here
net encoders and you can do the same for
decoders basically
the encoders and decoders don't need
this complicated mechanism going to
function compile
because they are not really part of the
network
they are sort of outside the network
they are df pre-processing
so we had this since quite a long time
already so yeah
will it train on gpu
so it will technically work if you
target device gpu
but will technically not run on gpu as
of now
it will copy back to cpu
run on cpu and go back to gpu
and this is because the compiler
currently is not able to compile to gpu
but it will in the future
so at some point it will it will also
run
natively in gpu which means you don't
basically there are no gains uh
train using this on gpu and if you train
a a network with a compiled layer on gpu
the compiled layer is likely to be a
bottleneck unless
the compiled layer is very simple you
know if the compiler has very simple
computation
that you have a lot of like you know
heavyweight convolutional layers on the
gpu then it will not be about lag
but you know it's more likely to be on
one like because
it runs in cpu and you also have to wait
for
um data copy from gpu back to cpu to get
the compiled layer to work and transfer
the data back to you
will nuts including these infer on
raspberry pi
um i think so
i'm not exactly sure the compiler i mean
i'm
not going to make the promise that the
compiler can compile on arm
but i would guess so honestly
i didn't try but if if function compile
works on raspberry pi
then this works raspberry pi
if there is a random number used in
compile layer can we keep it
the same in both forward and backward
huh
this is a tough question
so the question i think it means if you
generate okay so
yeah here's a way to to see this if you
generate
the number inside the compiled layer
there is cur there is currently there is
no way to to keep it
but it can be possible this is
interesting it can be
can be made possible
by using the uh
yeah at least theoretically you can use
mx as a functionality to do that let's
let's say this
it has auxiliary arrays which are for
example used by batch romanization layer
problem is we don't have an analog of
that top level so it might
be hard to to add
but it's definitely something
interesting that we should look into
one other option is that you you
generate the
random number outside the layer if you
generate another number outside the
layer then the random number is an input
to the layer
and if it's an input to the layer then
you get the same random number
in the backward pass because of
because of this so when you do the
backward you reduce the input and so if
you
generate the number outside you will be
able to do it
but but you need multiple input output
because
you will need the the port for the
actual input
besides the random number so it will not
be possible
mateo it looks like you have a couple
chat uh questions in the zoom chat too
okay sorry i stopped
yeah i stopped looking at those because
questions were coming
yeah they were going in the path of the
chat
um so is it on the zoom chat
or on yeah it's under the zoom yes
okay
okay so the first question is a
compilation of questions which you have
really answered
okay no it's yeah there are no new
questions then there is a comment from
roadmap
so yeah no new questions
okay since there are no more questions
are we going to stop this